every time they mention this next fellow
every time they mention and they say he
started out as a hoofer that he became a
fine dramatic actor a great light
comedian he was president of a Screen
Actors Guild a stout fella beloved by
everybody everybody beloved by him in
fact people say so many nice things
about the FEL you think he was dead the
prove he's not here he is mr. George
Murphy
thank you Paul I may not be dead but I
certainly feel dressed for it thank you
my job here tonight is to make the
awards for documentary films documentary
film has been called the creative
reporting of social facts on film
certainly the pictures which have been
nominated for the award this year fit
that definition exactly they are a
chance to live March of time Richard de
Rougemont producer 20th Century Fox 1848
ANF films produced by French cinema
general cooperative the rising tide
National Film Board of Canada produced
by st. Francis Xavier University and so
much for so little Warner Brothers
cartoons Edward Seltzer producer the
special envelope please
the winners are a chance to live March
of time produced by Richard de Mer de
Rougemont 20th Century Fox and so much
for so little Warner Brothers cartoons
produced by Edward Seltzer it was a tie
lady
even chance to live
the water is being accepted by Colonel
Jason a straw
and so much for little the award is
being accepted by mr. Edward Selzer this
is a Warner Brothers picture our first
tie of the evening and documentary short
subjects Colonel Jason s joy of 20th
Century Fox studio accepted the award
for the chance to live mr. Murphy thank
you those nominated for feature
documentary are they breaking you d
British information services produced by
Crown film unit and Kenji comes home a
Protestant film commissioned production
Paul effort producer I have the
envelopes they break in you d British
information services produced by Crown
film you
I should say by Robert Henry heaven
mr. robert henry hado
british consul general in los angeles
accepted the award and thank you George
Murphy